okay what have we got today what's going
on what's this about we're talking about
my favorite subject black holes Oh I
thought I thought it was going to be
friends
it's not friends it's not Taylor Swift
and it's not Hamilton sorry uh it's
Black Horse and I want to ask you Brody
what do you think is the most massive
black hole that we know of
the biggest
how big
do you reckon it is 10 billion Suns 10
million 10 billion solar man I imagine
it's one of those ones that's at the
center of a really big Galaxy exactly
yeah so it's a supermassive black hole
Yeah it's one of the biggest we found
and 10 billion between friends I'll give
you that okay 66 billion times the mass
of the sun is the biggest supermassive
black hole we've found it's monstrously
large so the Milky Way's black hole at
the center of our galaxy is four million
times the mass of the Sun the
Supermassive Black core at the center of
Messier 87 that we had the image of back
in 2019 6.5 billion times the master Sun
ton 618
supermassive black hole 66 billion times
the mass of the Sun bigger than the
entire mass of everything in the Milky
Way But crushed down into a space that's
smaller than the solar system like it's
we needed a new name for it people have
started calling it Ultra massive black
hole when we talk about the size of a
black hole we're talking about the size
of the Event Horizon so the point of no
return essentially the sort of sphere
around that Singularity that is the part
where we're no longer getting any more
light from getting no information from
data from if you crossed it you'd become
a Cropper you'd never come back out
again question is
can it get any bigger
is there a upper limit to how big black
holes can grow and you might think well
no black holes will just pull everything
and anything in but that's not how what
we call the accretion process works so
accretion is like a fancy physics word
essentially to mean bring in under
Gravity you think well black holes have
the strongest gravity surely they can
just bring stuff in but we have to
remember that most material
when you've got a massive object will
just orbit an object so to get stuff to
go from being in orbit to not being in
orbit and actually falling in towards
the black hole you'd have to somehow
remove energy from it maybe a cloud of
gas very unsuspecting comes in towards a
black hole and it gets turned from you
know like a sphere into essentially a
disc and in that disc that's where
you've got all of these collisions going
on and eventually some of the stuff will
collide lose energy and spiral in
towards the black hole so when we think
about this process happening there's a
couple of different things we have to
think about almost like different
circles that we could draw around the
black hole we already heard about one of
them that was the event horizon that's
one sphere that you could draw around
the black hole is that point of no
return another Circle you can draw is
called the innermost stable circular
orbit Isco the Isco essentially is the
point where you can have a stable orbit
around the black hole which doesn't
really check out if we think about
gravity the way that Newton thought
about it say you had something in orbit
around the sun like very close to its
surface in a perfectly circular orbit
nudge it slightly to send it onto an
elliptical orbit it could do that it
could change its orbit and shift it
slightly to be elliptical orbit rather
than a perfect circle and still stay
around the Sun rather than falling in in
Einstein's theory of gravity there is a
point at which you can't do that anymore
you have a last stable circular orbit
you cannot adjust your orbit in any way
if you've been nudged and lost energy at
that point the only way is down you're
right on the it's the you're right on
the edge of survival exactly right so
the Isco is usually it defines the
innermost point of what we call that
accretion disc that disc of essentially
hydrogen gas swirling matter around the
black hole that hopefully will fall in
and grow the black holes Mass so that's
how the majority of black holes grow
sometimes you can have a merger of two
black holes so for example if you have
two galaxies that merge together the
supermassive black holes in the center
will also presumably merge but mergers
aren't very common they're quite rare
they happen over billions of years for
example like Andromeda in the Milky Way
will merge but in four or five billion
years time they'll meet and it'll
probably take another few billion years
for their black holes to finally slosh
together and eventually emerge so in the
rest of the time it's the secretion
process that's driving the growth so
both the Event Horizon and the Isco that
sphere that you draw around a black hole
that gets bigger and bigger with mass so
like we were talking about before the
event horizon the bigger the black hole
the bigger that pushes out same with the
innermost stable circular orbit and the
self-gravitational radius another Circle
or sphere you can draw around the black
hole is essentially why we have a galaxy
of stars around the supermassive black
hole in the center in the first place
it's the radius Beyond which
say you have a star the gravity of the
star holding the star together is
stronger than the pull that it feels
from the black hole if you didn't have
that we wouldn't have a galaxy of stars
right we just have a big accretion disk
and it's just all hydrogen gas just
hundreds of thousands of light years
wide all waiting to go into the black
hole he couldn't have structures exactly
you couldn't have structures at all if
you didn't have this self-gravitational
radius Andrew King who is Professor at
Leicester was thinking about this back
in 2015. and he realized actually that
as you grow bigger and bigger there is a
point at which that innermost stable
circular orbit goes beyond the
self-gravitational radius
so the edge of your accretion disk
is at the point where all of the stuff
in the accretion disk is attracted more
to each other
than it is to the black hole so no
matter how many collisions they have to
exchange energy
they will never actually cross that
innermost stable circular orbit and end
up into the black hole so any gas that
you bring into orbit around the black
hole is more like to start clumping into
itself and hopefully get very dense and
maybe kick start formation or I don't
know some planetary system around to
Black Hole or something like that right
that's the more likely thing to happen
than for this accretion process where
the black hole grows
and so you realize that there's
therefore this limit almost at which a
black hole can't grow by this process
anymore the only way it could grow is if
it had a merger with another one or if
you had material on literally like the
bullseye trajectory right like straight
down into the black hole the freak
Collision yeah exactly it would be very
very rare and if you work out how big
that is that limit at which point the
Isco goes beyond the self-gravitational
radius
it's around about 50 billion times the
mass of the song which obviously is
smaller than ton618 is 66 billion but
it's because you've taken it's a lot of
assumptions to get the maths to do it
you assume the black hole is not
spinning which if the black hole is
spinning it does change things slightly
and it can push that higher how high is
debated could be up to 60 could be up to
70 billion times the mass of the sun
but it still doesn't change the fact
that ton61a at 66 billion times the
master sun is getting towards that limit
it's reaching the point where it can't
grow through accretion anymore through
that disc around it and the thing is
those discs around it they're the things
that glow in x-rays ultraviolet infrared
so that we can see these things billions
of years across the universe and we can
also measure the supermassive black
holes masses with the light from that
disc as well so the idea that it might
be reaching its peak
suggest that there could already be
other black holes in the universe that
have already reached their Peak
that we can no longer see and know that
they're there or measure how heavy they
are
and that we could be living through this
era of sort of the end of black holes
it's like they're retired yes yeah it's
like they've gone dormant finally like a
volcano you know or something like that
which is exciting to think about that we
could be living through that era of you
know black holes reaching the maximum
they can grow to but also kind of sad
can the Milky Ways Whopper of a black
hole Reach This limit like has it got
enough food or will it will it never get
to that kind of proportion so the Milky
Way is black hole is pretty piddly not
just because it's only four million
times the master Sun but there is a
correlation as well a rough correlation
between the total mass in stars in a
galaxy and the total mass in the black
hole and so you see this sort of as a
nice correlation nice line and a lot of
galaxies you know scatter around this
line the Milky Way's work call is quite
far below it like you'd expect it to be
much larger for the size of the Galaxy
than it is now this could be the reason
that we're all here because if it's not
grown very much do the secretion process
that can actually you know throw out a
lot of high energy radiation can
sometimes get pressure building in that
accretion disk and it sort of gives off
a little burp of an outflow as we call
it or a jet and that can radiate through
the Galaxy and it could have serious
issues for life on any Planet so the
fact that milky Way's black hole is
small because it's not grown could be
the reason why we were given a nice safe
place to evolve for the past fourbs I
believe is or so so that's an
interesting thought
but because it's so small I mean yes it
has the theoretical ability to grow that
big just whether it will or not is a
question to become like ton618 it would
probably need five ten more mergers of
galaxies all coming together it's likely
that what ton-618 is is what we call a
Galaxy cluster fossil so essentially you
had a cluster of galaxies in the past
say 10 Galaxies all come together and
they've all merged together into one
over the universe's history and that's
likely what's formed this giant Behemoth
of a galaxy and Ultra massive black hole
Galaxy cluster fossil yeah you guys are
the best at naming
the GCF really if we're doing what we're
actually doing right
this is your book about black holes yes
it's in them you can buy it in America
now as well you go and yeah it's out
worldwide now so wherever you are you
should be able to get a copy uh you can
get it in hardback or I also did the
audiobook version as well so you can
have me read it to you if you sign mine
yeah there we go
oh wow
go and read it for us it says to Brady
thanks for giving me my start on YouTube
Dr Becky November 2022. now I want one
more thing yeah I want you to draw a
black hole for me you're a black hole
okay how did you draw a black hole
um I guess a little bit like how they
had it in interstellar for everyone
who's who's seen it is you get the light
bent around it right and then you have
this accretion disc so that is the
accretion disc
of material there's sort of the Event
Horizon the shadow where you no longer
get in any light and then that's the
light of the accretion disk from behind
it bent around to the top of the black
hole
thank you very much and there's the name
of the book everyone Link in the
description yeah
Starbucks that's taking place the fact
that it's not it's not is really
interesting for spiral galaxies we
expect them to be very blue and very
start for me blue light essentially
means the hottest brightest biggest
stars in